This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. A few years ago, social scientist Francesca Gina was browsing the shelves at her local bookstore when she came across an unusual looking book in the cooking section. This recipe book, they look a little bit different and the title said, never trust a skinny Italian chef. And being Italian, it was very intrigued, and as I flipped through the pages, it became clear that this was not your typical recipe book. The dishes were playful, quirky, and improbable. Snails were paired with coffee sauce, vial tang with charcoal powder.
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。几年前，社会科学家弗朗西斯卡·吉诺在当地书店浏览书架时，在烹饪区偶然发现了一本看起来很不寻常的书。这本食谱看起来有点不同，书名是《永远不要相信一个瘦弱的意大利厨师》。作为意大利人，她非常好奇，当我翻阅书页时，很明显这不是一本普通的食谱。这些菜肴既俏皮、古怪，又令人难以置信。蜗牛配咖啡酱，小牛舌配木炭粉。
The recipes had titles like how to burn a sardine. And, oops, I dropped the lemon tart. There were pictures of beautiful dishes who could resist the a dish called the crunchy part of the lasagna. Now, if you know anything about Italians, first of all, we have lots of rules when it comes to cooking. And second, we really cherish our traditional dishes, especially because they've been passed on for generations.
食谱的标题有《如何烧焦沙丁鱼》和《哎呀，我把柠檬挞掉地上了》。书里有精美菜肴的照片，谁能抵挡得住一道名为《千层面酥脆的部分》的菜呢？现在，如果你对意大利人有所了解，首先，我们在烹饪方面有很多规矩。其次，我们非常珍视我们的传统菜肴，尤其是因为它们代代相传。
But this chef, one of the most successful in the world, couldn't resist circling back to one big existential question. Why is it that we cook the dish in this way? TICKING TICKING TICKING TICKING Why is it that we cook the dish in this way? Why is it that we cook the dish in this way? It's the kind of question Francesca loved. As a professor at Harvard Business School, she studies non-conformance, specifically
但这位厨师，作为世界上最成功的厨师之一，却忍不住回到了一个重大的存在主义问题上。为什么我们以这种方式烹饪这道菜？为什么我们以这种方式烹饪这道菜？为什么我们以这种方式烹饪这道菜？这正是弗朗西斯卡喜欢的那种问题。作为哈佛商学院的教授，她研究不墨守成规，特别是
people who break the rules and end up in trouble. But now, standing at the bookstore, she wondered, can define norms lead to innovation, can let it go of tradition lead to the most sublime examples of creative thinking. To find out, she got in touch with a man behind the cookbook, the so-called Jimmy Hendrix of Italian cooking, Massimo Batura. After a few conversations, you said, luck, if you really want to understand the business, you've got to come to Malena.
那些打破规则最终陷入麻烦的人。但现在，站在书店里，她想知道，定义规范能否带来创新，放弃传统能否带来最具创造性思维的崇高范例。为了找出答案，她联系了这本食谱背后的男人，也就是所谓的意大利烹饪界的吉米·亨德里克斯——马西莫·博图拉。经过几次交谈，他说，看，如果你真的想了解这项业务，你必须来摩德纳。
And I was like, of course, why say no to an invitation to a three Michelin star restaurant? I'm on my way. This week, we'll revisit a favorite conversation with Francesca about her mission to understand the minds of successful non-conformists. I think we really need to shift our thinking. Rebels are not troublemakers, they're not outcast. Rebels are people who break rules that should be broken. They break
我当时想，当然，为什么拒绝去一家米其林三星餐厅的邀请呢？我已经在路上了。本周，我们将重温与弗朗西斯卡的一次精彩对话，探讨她了解成功的不墨守成规者思想的使命。我认为我们真的需要转变思维。叛逆者不是捣乱者，他们不是被排斥的人。叛逆者是打破那些应该被打破的规则的人。他们打破
rules that hold them and others back and the way of rule breaking is constructive rather than destructive. It creates positive change. Cultivating your inner rebel. This week on Hidden Brain. Francesca Gino is a busy person. She teaches at the Harvard Business School. She is a prolific researcher and writer. She advises corporations and nonprofit organizations on decision-making and negotiations. So she has no shortage of things on her to-do list. But when chef Massimo Boutura offered her the chance to watch him in action at his restaurant,
那些阻碍他们和其他人的规则，这种打破规则的方式是建设性的，而不是破坏性的。它创造了积极的改变。培养你内心的叛逆者。本周在《Hidden Brain》节目中。弗朗西斯卡·吉诺是一个忙碌的人。她在哈佛商学院任教。她是一位多产的研究员和作家。她为企业和非营利组织提供决策和谈判方面的建议。所以她的待办事项清单上从不缺少事情。但当厨师马西莫·博图拉给她机会在餐厅观察他的工作时，
she knew she needed to hop on a plane and go to Italy. So I showed up at the restaurant for my first day with my notebook and basically was given an apron. For the entire day I was put to work in the front of the house as a server. And again, it was an amazing experience because I had no qualification. I clearly didn't know what I was doing. I made a lot of mistakes, but that was just an example of doing things a little bit differently. So of course, if you're a smart chef, the one thing you don't do is bring an amateur into your three Michelin style restaurant and ask her to start serving the dishes, I can just imagine all the ways that that could go wrong, did it?
她知道她需要跳上飞机去意大利。所以我带着笔记本出现在餐厅的第一天，基本上被发了一件围裙。整整一天，我都被安排在前厅做服务员。这又是一次了不起的经历，因为我没有任何资格。我显然不知道自己在做什么。我犯了很多错误，但这只是以不同方式做事的一个例子。所以当然，如果你是一个聪明的厨师，你绝对不会做的一件事就是把一个业余爱好者带进你的米其林三星餐厅，让她开始上菜，我简直可以想象所有可能出错的方式，真的吗？
That is exactly what was going through my head as I was making mistakes, from putting the very carefully arranged dishes down onto the table, that are very specific ways in which the dish gets arranged so that you get the right anticipation of what the dish is going to be about as you edit. And throughout the day, the team members were working with me in the front of the house were just helping me. And when I was making mistakes, they were very subtly trying to correct us. So they were adjusting the plate or if I brought to a table the wrong utensils that they would show up, somehow bring another set that was the rice set for the type of dish that was being served.
这正是我在犯错时脑子里想的事情，比如把精心摆放的菜肴放到桌子上，菜肴的摆放方式非常具体，这样你就能在编辑时对这道菜的内容有正确的预期。整整一天，在前厅和我一起工作的团队成员都在帮助我。当我犯错时，他们会非常微妙地试图纠正我们。所以他们会调整盘子，或者如果我给桌子拿错了餐具，他们就会出现，不知怎么地拿来另一套适合所上菜肴的餐具。
So I understand that if I were to visit the restaurant, I might sometimes see Massimo Batura outside, unloading produce from the trucks or sweeping the pavement. He doesn't seem like someone who stands on airs. He's very much into the trenches. One of the first things that he does when he shows up at the restaurant in the morning is to put his white chef's coat on, and then he does go outside with a broom and sweep the streets. And you're there looking at him, and the sous chef and the people working in the restaurants are there looking at him and you ask the question, why is it that he's doing that? But the second question that you ask yourself is, why is it that I'm not doing it? And so you're feeling motivated
所以我明白，如果我去餐厅参观，我有时可能会看到马西莫·博图拉在外面，从卡车上卸下农产品或清扫人行道。他看起来不像是一个摆架子的人。他非常深入一线。他早上到餐厅做的第一件事就是穿上白色的厨师服，然后拿着扫帚去外面清扫街道。你站在那里看着他，副主厨和在餐厅工作的人都在那里看着他，你会问这个问题，他为什么要那样做？但你问自己的第二个问题是，为什么我不那样做？所以你感到有动力
to take on roles and activities that are roles that are not scripted because of where you sit or where you work in the restaurant. It's very refreshing. And of course, he actually tries to bring this approach to the food that he's making as well. I want you to listen to this clip of music because you say the chef actually asked his staff to build a dish based on this song. So what was going on, Francesca, how do you make a walk on the wild side. Said he honey.
去承担那些不是因为你在餐厅的位置或工作地点而设定的角色和活动。这非常令人耳目一新。当然，他实际上也试图将这种方法应用到他制作的食物中。我想让你听听这段音乐，因为你说厨师实际上要求他的员工根据这首歌制作一道菜。那么发生了什么，弗朗西斯卡，你是如何走在狂野一面的。他说亲爱的。
Take a walk on the wild side. So what was going on Francesca? How do you make a dish based on a song? It was one of the many ways that Massimo Bhattura inspires the people working in the kitchen and really asked them to bring out their own contribution and their own voices. So you would see him walk into the kitchen
走在狂野的一面。那么发生了什么，弗朗西斯卡？你是如何根据一首歌制作一道菜的？这是马西莫·博图拉激励厨房工作人员并真正要求他们贡献自己的力量和声音的多种方式之一。所以你会看到他走进厨房
and say, Luri, walk to the side, or a different name of a song or a different poem or the name of a phrase of something that he was reading recently or the name of a piece of art that he saw at an art show. And what he's trying to do is is asking people to think about how that song or how that piece of art inspired them to come up with their own dish. And what is trying to do at the very core is making sure that people don't show up at work. And somehow they leave their identity at the door, but rather they show up and they are being who they are. They're bringing their ideas forward, their contributions forward,
说，走在狂野的一面，或者一首歌的不同名字，或者一首不同的诗，或者他最近读到的某个短语的名字，或者他在艺术展上看到的艺术品的名字。他试图做的是要求人们思考那首歌或那件艺术品是如何激励他们想出自己的菜肴的。他核心想要做的是确保人们不会只是出现在工作中，不知怎么地把他们的身份留在门外，而是他们出现并做他们自己。他们提出自己的想法，提出自己的贡献，
independent of their background, their nationalities, or how much training they have. And when you spoke to the staff at the restaurant, what did they say the role of the chef was in inspiring them? Did they actually agree that these techniques were actually bringing out the best in them? What the staff has said, which is really interesting, is that Massimo is the type of leader who
独立于他们的背景、国籍或他们接受了多少培训。当你和餐厅的员工交谈时，他们说厨师在激励他们方面的作用是什么？他们是否真的同意这些技巧确实发挥了他们最好的一面？员工们所说的是，这真的很有趣，马西莫是那种领导者，
never says, hi, hi, hi, is always about the we. He describes the restaurant as a crew or as a ship. As a, in fact, it often talks about being on a pirate ship. And sometimes the waters out there are going to be turbulent, but for the very fact that we are going to bring out our individual contributions, but we're going to do so, being aware that we are part of a team, no matter how terrible in the sea is we're gonna succeed. And people do feel very inspired by the way it leads the restaurant. Here's another thing that makes Massimo a rebel. He asks a lot of questions about why things are
从不说“我，我，我”，总是关于“我们”。他把餐厅描述为一个团队或一艘船。事实上，他经常谈论在一艘海盗船上。有时外面的水域会很动荡，但正是因为我们将贡献出个人的力量，但我们这样做时，会意识到我们是一个团队的一部分，无论大海多么可怕，我们都会成功。人们确实对他的餐厅领导方式感到非常鼓舞。这是让马西莫成为叛逆者的另一件事。他问了很多关于为什么事情是
the way they are. For Francesca, a fearless curiosity is at the heart of Rebel Talut. Butura opened up a restaurant by asking the question, why not? Yet no experience in running a restaurant, let alone cooking because he didn't go to culinary school. He was in law school. He was there for two years,
这样的问题。对于弗朗西斯卡来说，无畏的好奇心是叛逆者天赋的核心。博图拉通过问“为什么不呢？”这个问题开了一家餐厅。然而，他没有任何经营餐厅的经验，更不用说烹饪了，因为他没有上过烹饪学校。他在法学院。他在那里待了两年，
as a way to stick to what his father wanted, and then he didn't enjoy it. And one is brother, one of these brothers told him about this restaurant that was up for sale. He really asked himself the question, why not? That's curiosity. We are so often focused on efficiency and getting things done. We have a very long to do list. But what that often comes at the cost of is allowing us to explore the way we used to when we were a very little kid. And that came very naturally to us. So I see too many leaders who focus so much on efficiency, that curiosity shut
作为坚持他父亲意愿的一种方式，但他并不喜欢。当他的一个兄弟告诉他这家餐厅要出售时，他真的问了自己“为什么不呢？”的问题。这就是好奇心。我们经常专注于效率和完成工作。我们有很长的待办事项清单。但这样做往往是以牺牲我们像小时候那样探索的能力为代价的。这对我们来说非常自然。所以我看到太多的领导者过于关注效率，以至于好奇心在人们身上关闭了
down in people and that's too bad because curiosity leads to all sorts of great results and great outcomes. There's a tension that runs through much of the book and the tension is the tension between expertise and experimentation. And I want to come back and talk about this over and over again, but I also want to do it through the lens of another story that you explore You've looked at the story of Captain Chesley Salenberger, better known as Captain Sully He was at the controls of US Airways flight 1549 The plane had just taken off from La Guardia airport in New York a flock of birds
这太糟糕了，因为好奇心会导致各种伟大的结果和伟大的成果。书中贯穿着一种张力，这种张力是专业知识与实验之间的张力。我想回来反复谈论这一点，但我也想通过你探索的另一个故事的视角来谈论它。你研究了切斯利·萨伦伯格机长的故事，也就是萨利机长。他当时在全美航空1549号航班的控制室里。飞机刚从纽约拉瓜迪亚机场起飞，一群鸟
Flies into the plane. I want to play you a bit of tape from the cockpit recorder. Captain Sully Radio's air traffic controllers in New York using the call sign, Cactus 1539. The plane is descending at a terrifying rate. The controllers try to figure out what to do. The captain Sally asks for landing options, but he quickly decides none of them will work. I'm taking a shirt he's going with us. I took 15.9. He's on. I took 15.9. Landing a plane in the Hudson River. Francesca, you describe this incident as a striking example of rebel talent. Why?
飞进了飞机。我想给你播放一点驾驶舱记录仪的录音。萨利机长使用呼号“仙人掌1539”与纽约的空中交通管制员通话。飞机正以惊人的速度下降。管制员试图弄清楚该做什么。萨利机长询问着陆选项，但他很快决定没有一个能行得通。我要去哈德逊河。我正在去哈德逊河的路上。在哈德逊河上降落飞机。弗朗西斯卡，你将这次事件描述为叛逆者天赋的一个显著例子。为什么？
If you think about the situation that Captain Sally was under, most of us would go to the obvious answer. We are under a lot of pressure. We have no time. We are really stressed. And what our mind would do very naturally is to narrow our way of thinking. But if you read the accident reports or if you were to talk to Sally, you would understand that what he did instead was to consider options. He kept asking himself what it is that I could be doing. And in a place where most people would close their mind, he kept his mind open. Rather than going to the obvious answer of lending to the nearest airport, he thought creative about the problem and came up with this idea of lending in the
如果你考虑萨利机长所处的环境，我们大多数人会选择显而易见的答案。我们承受着巨大的压力。我们没有时间。我们真的很紧张。我们的头脑会非常自然地缩小我们的思维方式。但如果你阅读事故报告，或者如果你和萨利交谈，你会明白他所做的是考虑各种选择。他不断问自己我能做什么。在一个大多数人会封闭思想的地方，他保持了开放的心态。他没有选择降落在最近的机场这个显而易见的答案，而是对这个问题进行了创造性的思考，并想出了在
Attsum River. So that's what rebels are all about. People who rather than just following the script or just following what they've learned in their training, they stay open-minded. They look at the problem from very different perspective, no matter how much time they have to think about it and then they creatively solve the problem from very different perspective, no matter how much time they have to think about it, and then they creatively solve the problem. Captain Sally had 208 seconds. By the time he discovered that he had no thrust in the engine and the time he ditched the plane in the Atson River, that's
哈德逊河降落的想法。这就是叛逆者的全部意义所在。那些不只是遵循剧本或只遵循他们在训练中学到的东西的人，他们保持开放的心态。他们从非常不同的角度看待问题，无论他们有多少时间去思考，然后他们创造性地解决问题。萨利机长有208秒。从他发现引擎没有推力到他将飞机迫降在哈德逊河的时间，那是
true, Rebel talent. One of the things again, the story reveals to me is this tension between expertise and experimentation. So, if you have expertise, but you're not willing to experiment, you become predictable, you become boring. But if you experiment without having expertise, that can be a matured. If you ask me to land a plane in the Hudson River, it's going to end in disaster. So there's something that happens when you combine expertise with experimentation. That's where the magic is. Exactly. One of the things that many people might not know about Captain Sally, that I learned when I had the opportunity to interview him, is that by the time the accident happened.
真正的叛逆者天赋。这个故事再次向我揭示的一件事是专业知识与实验之间的这种张力。所以，如果你有专业知识，但你不愿意尝试，你就会变得可预测，变得无聊。但如果你在没有专业知识的情况下进行实验，那可能是灾难性的。如果你让我把飞机降落在哈德逊河上，那将以灾难告终。所以当你把专业知识与实验结合起来时，会发生一些事情。这就是魔力所在。完全正确。很多人可能不知道关于萨利机长的一件事，是我在有机会采访他时了解到的，那就是事故发生时，
He had experience flying all sorts of planes. He also served as a volunteer in teams that look at prior accidents and try to understand what it is that it happened. So he had so much experience once he was in that dire situation. And yet, one of the things that is true about him is that every time he walked on a plane, he asked himself the question, what it is that I could learn. How is it that this could be different?
他有驾驶各种飞机的经验。他还曾作为志愿者参与调查先前事故的团队，并试图了解发生了什么。所以他在那种可怕的情况下拥有如此丰富的经验。然而，关于他的一件事是，每次他走上飞机，他都会问自己一个问题，我能学到什么？这怎么可能不同？
He had that type of intellectual humility that kept him open-minded despite the fact that he was accumulating throughout his career a lot of experience. That's what often we miss out on. We gain experience, and by gaining experience and knowledge, we believe that we all have the right answer. And we don't stay humble. We don't have that type of intellectual humility that keeps us focused on what's left to learn,
他拥有那种保持开放心态的知识谦逊，尽管他在职业生涯中积累了大量的经验。这往往是我们错过的。我们获得了经验，通过获得经验和知识，我们相信我们都拥有正确的答案。我们没有保持谦逊。我们没有那种让我们专注于还有什么需要学习的知识谦逊，
rather than what it is that we know already. Captain Sally and Massimo Batura tried daring things and achieved extraordinary results. It's easy to admire them, but why is it so hard to be like them? It turns out a curious psychological roadblock often gets in the way. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. We're talking about successful rebels, people who define the status quo and produce creative breakthroughs.
而不是我们已经知道的东西。萨利机长和马西莫·博图拉尝试了大胆的事情并取得了非凡的成果。钦佩他们很容易，但为什么像他们一样这么难呢？事实证明，一种好奇的心理障碍经常阻碍我们。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们正在谈论成功的叛逆者，那些定义现状并产生创造性突破的人。
We've seen how this worked with Captain Sully and Chef Potura. So why are people like this so rare? Why do so many of us find it hard to channel our inner Potura? You might think the problem is, when are experts? When are skills chefs or great pilots? But in fact, the problem is often the opposite. We know too much. Francesca Gino is a behavioral scientist at the Harvard Business School,
我们已经看到了这在萨利机长和博图拉厨师身上是如何运作的。那么为什么这样的人如此罕见？为什么我们许多人觉得很难引导我们内心的博图拉？你可能认为问题在于，什么时候是专家？什么时候是熟练的厨师或伟大的飞行员？但事实上，问题往往恰恰相反。我们知道得太多了。弗朗西斯卡·吉诺是哈佛商学院的行为科学家，
an author of Rebel Talent, why it pays to break the rules at work and in life. My colleagues and I were fascinated by this idea that experience could be costly. Because in a lot of our classes, we're actually there telling our students that they should gain knowledge, the information is power, that experience is important. And so we explored this in a data set of millions of data points on how cardiologists behave in their surgery when they do open our surgeries. And what was interesting is that we could explore what happened to this cardiologist and their
《叛逆者天赋：为什么在工作和生活中打破规则是有回报的》一书的作者。我和我的同事们对经验可能是有代价的这个想法很着迷。因为在我们的许多课程中，我们实际上是在告诉我们的学生，他们应该获得知识，信息就是力量，经验很重要。因此，我们在数百万个关于心脏病专家在进行心脏直视手术时如何表现的数据集中探索了这一点。有趣的是，我们可以探索这些心脏病专家发生了什么，以及他们的
behavior. After the Food and Drug Administration put out an announcement that if I were to simplify, basically told them that the way they were using the technology in their surgery was not good for patients. And what we found in the data that was striking is that the more experienced the surgeon had, the less likely they were to change their behavior. That means that as you were suggesting, when we gain experience often, we feel like the expert and we think that we know better,
行为。在食品药品监督管理局发布公告后，如果我将其简化，基本上是告诉他们，他们在手术中使用的技术对患者不利。我们在数据中发现了一个惊人的事实，即外科医生的经验越丰富，他们改变行为的可能性就越小。这意味着正如你所建议的那样，当我们获得经验时，我们往往会觉得自己是专家，认为自己更了解情况，
even when we hear information or when we see evidence that speaks to the fact and we think that we know better even when we hear information or when we see evidence that speaks to the fact that we're wrong. And so having that learning mindset as we're getting experience is so so important. And of course, that's difficult to do precisely because once you know something, you ask yourself, why should I go back to becoming a beginner, you describe a very interesting study that was done out of Columbia University looking at guitar players and one way that expert guitarists could learn to once again think like beginners. Tell me about that study.
即使当我们听到信息或看到证据表明我们错了时，我们仍然认为自己更了解情况。因此，在我们获得经验的同时保持这种学习心态非常非常重要。当然，这很难做到，恰恰是因为一旦你了解了某件事，你就会问自己，我为什么要回到初学者的状态？你描述了哥伦比亚大学进行的一项非常有趣的研究，研究对象是吉他手，专家吉他手可以重新像初学者一样思考的一种方式。跟我说说那项研究吧。
This is a study by Ting Zhang and she was fascinated by this idea that once you're an expert, it's very difficult to look at problems with the eyes of a novice. And so one way she thought she could address this very issue is by asking expert to relive the experience of being an novice. So in one of her studies, she recruited experienced people who play guitar. She asked some of them the control grew to play as they would on a typical day. Of course, they sounded great. She asked the others to play a song with their non-dominant hand. Leftees played with the right hand, righthanded people played with their left hand. It instantly made them feel like beginners again.
这是丁张（Ting Zhang）的一项研究，她对这样一个想法很着迷：一旦你成为专家，就很难用新手的眼光去看待问题。因此，她认为解决这个问题的办法之一是让专家重温作为新手的经历。在她的其中一项研究中，她招募了有经验的吉他手。她要求其中一些人（对照组）像往常一样演奏。当然，他们弹得很好。她要求其他人用非惯用手弹奏一首歌。左撇子用右手弹，右撇子用左手弹。这让他们立刻感觉自己又回到了初学者的状态。
The experience is very humbling because you are sort of reminded of what it is that you knew and didn't know as you started. And when she compared the advice that these people were giving to others who were interested in learning how to play the guitar, the advice was much more helpful when he came to this second group of people rather than the group of people who played the guitar as you would usually do. As I'm hearing you tell me about the guitar study, it reminds me of something else you have in the book. This insight that in many fields, the people who are the innovators are often not the people who've been in those fields for extended periods of time. It's often the newcomers to a field who have just about enough information to have mastered the rules, but I have not spent so much time in the culture that they've become hidebound. These are the people who are actually able to take the culture and move it in new directions.
这种经历非常令人谦卑，因为你会被提醒刚开始时你知道什么，不知道什么。当她比较这些人给其他有兴趣学习弹吉他的人的建议时，她发现这些建议对第二组人来说更有帮助，而不是对那些像往常一样弹吉他的人。当我听你讲吉他研究时，它让我想起了你在书中提到的另一件事。这种洞察力是，在许多领域，创新者往往不是那些在这些领域待了很长时间的人。通常是刚进入该领域的新手，他们掌握了足够的规则，但还没有在文化中花费太多时间以至于变得墨守成规。这些人实际上能够推动文化向新的方向发展。
You talk about the role of how this works in science. There have been people who have tried to solve scientific problems by inviting people who are not necessarily science experts, but people who are outsiders. It's quite interesting to think about the fact that probably all of us have had at some point in our lives or another, a moment in which we were trying to tackle a problem where we felt we were the expert, but we were stuck and we were not able to come up with a solution. And what is interesting is that when we in fact bring in people who might not have the right expertise, they're going to look at the problem from a very different perspective.
你谈到了这在科学中是如何运作的。有些人试图通过邀请不一定是科学专家，而是局外人的人来解决科学问题。想到这样一个事实，即我们所有人一生中可能都在某个时刻试图解决一个问题，当时我们觉得自己是专家，但却卡住了，无法想出解决方案，这非常有趣。有趣的是，当我们实际上引入可能没有相关专业知识的人时，他们会从一个非常不同的角度看待问题。
And that type of difference in perspective, in opinions, in the way you're looking and analyzing the problem, can be quite powerful in helping you find a solution. And there are companies out there that in fact have used this insight and created businesses like Ilai Lilly would be one of them where when there are very difficult challenges they put them out there such that not only the people with the right expertise might want to tackle the problem but all others people who might not have the right expertise can chime in and often the solutions come exactly from those people. It's a good reminder that expertise, while wonderful, creates potential problems if we use it as a way of saying, I know the answer, I'm the expert. You look at the problem tunearily,
这种在观点、看待和分析问题方式上的差异，在帮助你找到解决方案方面可能非常强大。确实有一些公司利用了这一洞察力并创建了业务，礼来公司（Eli Lilly）就是其中之一，当遇到非常困难的挑战时，他们会将其发布出来，这样不仅拥有正确专业知识的人可能想要解决这个问题，而且所有其他可能没有正确专业知识的人也可以参与进来，解决方案往往正是来自这些人。这是一个很好的提醒，即专业知识虽然很棒，但如果我们用它来表示“我知道答案，我是专家”，就会产生潜在的问题。你狭隘地看待问题，
usually only from one perspective, and it's our own perspective. And instead, having this learning mindset mindset bringing in novices into the problem allows us to now look at the situation from many different angles and viewpoints. Of course, the speaks to the idea of the value of diversity. I think that's one of the insights that I'm getting from what you just said. Having a mix of people in the room who look at things from different perspectives could just be inherently valuable. Having people who look at the problem from very different perspective is, in fact, a key
通常只从一个角度，也就是我们自己的角度。相反，拥有这种学习心态，将新手引入问题，使我们现在能够从许多不同的角度和观点来看待情况。当然，这谈到了多样性的价值。我认为这是我从你刚才所说的话中得到的见解之一。在房间里混合那些从不同角度看待事物的人本身就可能非常有价值。拥有从非常不同的角度看待问题的人，实际上是解决难题的关键。
to solving tough problems. But the reality is that many of us don't want to be challenged. It's so much easier to go through life, whether I work or at home for that matter. We people that just nod their heads and say, yep, I agree with you. But rebel leaders and rebel employees are people who really try to surround themselves with people who think differently and with people who do challenge them. I asked Francesca about another rebel she mentions in her book, the filmmaker Eva Duverne. You might be familiar with her work in movies such as Selma, an account of a series of famous
但现实是，我们许多人不想受到挑战。无论是在工作还是在家里，过日子都要容易得多。我们喜欢那些只会点头说“是的，我同意你”的人。但叛逆的领导者和叛逆的员工是那些真正试图让自己周围的人与众不同，并挑战他们的人。我问弗朗西斯卡关于她在书中提到的另一位叛逆者，电影制作人艾娃·杜威内（Ava DuVernay）。你可能熟悉她在电影《塞尔玛》（Selma）中的作品，这是对1965年由马丁·路德·金领导的一系列著名
civil rights marches led by Martin Luther King, Jr. in 1965. That means protest, that means march, that means disturb the peace, that means jail, that means risk, and that is hard. And you say that her story reveals another really important idea when it comes to rebel talent, which is the importance of being vigilant to stereotypes, to recognize that stereotypes can actually serve as a kind of straight jacket that prevents us from thinking creatively. In all sorts of spheres of life, we are affected by stereotypes. Or more generally, we accept social roles that others have passed on to us. And the story of Eva Duverne is a beautiful one because she just doesn't do that. And this comes from a person who decided to go to filmmaking
民权游行的描述。这意味着抗议，这意味着游行，这意味着扰乱治安，这意味着入狱，这意味着冒险，这很艰难。你说她的故事揭示了关于叛逆天赋的另一个非常重要的想法，那就是警惕刻板印象的重要性，认识到刻板印象实际上可以作为一种束缚我们创造性思维的紧身衣。在生活的各个领域，我们都受到刻板印象的影响。或者更广泛地说，我们接受了别人传给我们的社会角色。艾娃·杜威内的故事很美，因为她根本不那样做。这来自一个决定在职业生涯后期从事电影制作的人。
later in her career. She was doing a different job and she said, I'm gonna switch and enter this job. And in the advice that she was receiving from others, everybody was talking about the importance of really being supported by others, reaching out to networks. She didn't have that.
她当时在做一份不同的工作，她说，我要转行进入这份工作。在从别人那里得到的建议中，每个人都在谈论真正得到他人支持、接触网络的重要性。她没有这些。
And she just started picking up the camera and working on our own movies. And in fact, the first films she created were supported by her own savings. And then she became known for the work that she was doing, for the fact that she was not accepting the rules of the business, but in a sense, she was working and finding against them.
她只是开始拿起摄像机，自己制作电影。事实上，她创作的第一批电影是由她自己的积蓄支持的。然后，她因自己的工作而闻名，因为她不接受商业规则，但在某种意义上，她是在工作并与它们抗争。
And it's quite amazing and inspiring as a story. And so for me, I made my first film, my first speech film when I was 38. So it's never too late. That I just started from the outside. I just started from the outside. Rebels constructively break the rules. They push ahead even when they don't have the support of power brokers. And once they achieve success, they continue to think like beginners
这是一个非常令人惊叹和鼓舞人心的故事。所以对我来说，我在38岁时制作了我的第一部电影，我的第一部演讲电影。所以永远都不晚。我只是从外部开始。我只是从外部开始。叛逆者建设性地打破规则。即使在没有权力掮客支持的情况下，他们也会继续前进。一旦他们取得成功，他们就会继续像初学者一样思考，
and go out of their way to learn from those who disagree with them. So how can you activate your inner non-conformist? That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Today we're talking about rebels, people who break free of social norms and achieve incredible feats of imagination. Why is this something so few of us do? One problem is that we know too much. We become experts in our fields and then fall back on familiar routines. We forget how to see the world with fresh eyes. But it doesn't have to be this way. Francesca Gino says that being a rebel is a skill that all of us can cultivate. Sometimes it takes only small steps. A few years ago,
并竭尽全力向那些不同意他们的人学习。那么，你如何激活你内心的非顺从者呢？休息回来后我们再谈。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain），我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。今天我们谈论的是叛逆者，那些打破社会规范并实现令人难以置信的想象力壮举的人。为什么我们中很少有人这样做？一个问题是我们知道得太多了。我们成为各自领域的专家，然后退回到熟悉的常规中。我们忘记了如何用新鲜的眼光看待世界。但这不必如此。弗朗西斯卡·吉诺（Francesca Gino）说，成为叛逆者是我们所有人都可以培养的一种技能。有时只需要小步骤。几年前，
she wondered if getting people to feel comfortable about being uncomfortable could be the first step in activating their inner rebel. She asked students to stand before their friends and classmates and sing, don't stop believing, by journey. Can you set up the experiment for me, Francesca? I'm putting my hand in my hair as I was reminded when I was running this study. This was a study that was inspired by the notion that when we break rules, when we break away from what others people expect of us, we feel a sense of confidence. And so to test that, I brought undergraduates to the lab, and I asked them to engage in the test that you just heard. Stand up in front of a video with a microphone, and in front of other participants watching you singing, don't stop believing, that was one of the songs.
她想知道让人们对不舒服感到舒适是否是激活他们内心叛逆者的第一步。她让学生站在朋友和同学面前唱歌，唱Journey乐队的《Don't Stop Believin'》。你能为我设置这个实验吗，弗朗西斯卡？当我被提醒我在进行这项研究时，我把手放在头发上。这项研究的灵感来自于这样一个概念：当我们打破规则，当我们脱离别人对我们的期望时，我们会感到一种自信。因此，为了测试这一点，我把本科生带到实验室，我让他们参与你刚才听到的任务。站在麦克风前的视频前，在其他参与者看着你唱歌的情况下，唱《Don't Stop Believin'》，那是其中一首歌。
And some of the participants did just that, but some others were asked to wear a bandana as they were singing. Something that they told me made them uncomfortable. And then I was interested in seeing whether the anxiety and stress that they experienced during the task and the level of confidence in addition to their performance was going to be different in these two different conditions. And he was, both looking at physiological measure of stress, but also their self-reported measures in answering the question of how confident they felt. People who were wearing the bandana while they were singing in front of their peers felt more confident, felt less stress. So despite the fact that they thought they would feel more uncomfortable and that it would be harder for them,
一些参与者确实做到了，但另一些人被要求在唱歌时戴上头巾。他们告诉我这让他们感到不舒服。然后我有兴趣看看他们在任务中经历的焦虑和压力，以及除了表现之外的自信水平在这些不同的条件下是否会有所不同。确实如此，既观察了压力的生理指标，也观察了他们在回答关于他们感到多自信的问题时的自我报告指标。在同龄人面前唱歌时戴着头巾的人感到更自信，压力更小。所以尽管他们认为自己会感到更不舒服，而且这对他们来说会更难，
the fact that they were wearing their bandana, something that the peers didn't expect, was actually helpful to them. The fact that they were wearing their bandana, something that the peers didn't expect, was actually helpful to them. And this is not just their feelings and their physiology. When you look at the performance in terms of how much they stay on tune since the karaoke was recording that objectively, they did better. So there's a paradox here because in the one case you're asking one set of students to sing the song which is clearly difficult and especially before your friends in a classroom it's difficult to do but the second group is being asked to do something even more difficult you're asking them to sing the song and also where there's non-conforming you know headdress and you would think that the second group would do worse, but you found exactly the opposite.
事实上，他们戴着头巾，这是同龄人没想到的，这对他们实际上是有帮助的。事实上，他们戴着头巾，这是同龄人没想到的，这对他们实际上是有帮助的。这不仅仅是他们的感受和生理机能。当你从卡拉OK客观记录的音准保持程度来看表现时，他们做得更好。所以这里有一个悖论，因为在一种情况下，你要求一组学生唱歌，这显然很困难，特别是在教室里的朋友面前，这很难做到，但第二组被要求做一些更困难的事情，你要求他们唱歌，还要戴上这种不顺从的头饰，你会认为第二组会表现得更差，但你发现的恰恰相反。
Exactly. Oftentimes, we think that breaking rules is going to lead to worse outcomes, and it's going to make us feel uncomfortable, and it does, to a certain extent, but it then turns into confidence. And that confidence translates in better performance. It is paradoxical, but it's one of the big lessons in being rebelliousness. It does pay off. I understand that you've discovered this about yourself as well.
没错。通常，我们认为打破规则会导致更糟糕的结果，并且会让我们感到不舒服，在某种程度上确实如此，但它随后会转化为自信。而这种自信转化为更好的表现。这很矛盾，但这是叛逆的重要教训之一。它确实有回报。我了解到你也发现了关于你自己的这一点。
You've run experiments of a sort where you try on the effects of different kinds of footwear and the effects it has on your audiences. One time I was asked to teach two classes, the same class back to back. And in each class, I had 110 executives. And since I was teaching the same content across the two classes, what I thought I could do is change my shoes in between the two classes.
你进行过某种实验，尝试不同类型的鞋子对你的观众产生的影响。有一次，我被要求连续教授两门相同的课程。在每门课中，我都有110名高管。由于我在两门课中教授相同的内容，我想我可以做的是在两门课之间换鞋。
And that's exactly what I did. So picture, this professor dressed up in a really nice suit. And for the first class, I was wearing formal leather shoes. Probably what the students expected from a HBS professor or a professor in general teaching in an exec head. But for the second class, I changed out my leather shoes for a pair of red sneakers. And it was
我就是这么做的。所以想象一下，这位教授穿着一套非常漂亮的西装。在第一节课上，我穿着正式的皮鞋。这可能是学生们对哈佛商学院教授或一般在行政主管课程中教学的教授的期望。但在第二节课上，我把皮鞋换成了一双红色运动鞋。而且
interesting to walk to class. My colleagues were giving me the strange look, thinking what it is that she's doing, and I was going to teach my second class. And at the end of each of the two classes, I gave the executives a little survey. And in the survey, I was asking them question like, how much do you think I charge for my consulting? How much influence do you think I have? HBS as a professor. How often do you think I publish in a practitioner-oriented magazine like Harvard Business Review? And what was interesting is that these are measures that capture how much influence the student thought I had.
走进教室很有趣。我的同事们用奇怪的眼神看着我，心想她在做什么，而我正要去教我的第二节课。在每节课结束时，我给高管们做了一个小调查。在调查中，我问他们诸如“你认为我的咨询费是多少？”、“你认为我有多大的影响力？”、“作为哈佛商学院的教授，你认为我多久在《哈佛商业评论》这样的从业者导向杂志上发表文章？”等问题。有趣的是，这些指标捕捉到了学生认为我有多大的影响力。
And what the survey results showed is that they had higher respect. They thought of me as a more influential person. What I taught them, the same content, just wearing red sneakers. So of course, people listening to this are going to go out and get red sneakers and wear bandanas tomorrow, because that's what you're saying is going to get them taken more seriously. I recently did a training for a company around the issues of Rebel Talent
调查结果显示，他们有更高的尊重。他们认为我是一个更有影响力的人。我教给他们的内容是一样的，只是穿着红色运动鞋。所以当然，听这个的人明天会出去买红色运动鞋和戴头巾，因为这就是你说会让他们被更认真对待的原因。我最近为一家公司做了一次关于叛逆天赋问题的培训，
and the people who invited me out were all in a team wearing red sneakers and they got a lot of compliments and questions throughout the day. So, yeah, so that could be one of the lessons learned out of this research. Another way we can all get better at breaking the rules is to stay mindful of the things happening around us. Sometimes we're so focused on the job at hand that we fail to see how the situation might afford us opportunities to demonstrate leadership and authenticity. Maurice Cheeks had such an opportunity on April 25, 2003 during the NBA playoffs. Maurice was coach of the Portland Trail Blazers and his team was down 2-0 in the series. It was
邀请我去的那些人都在团队中穿着红色运动鞋，他们整天都得到很多赞美和提问。所以，是的，这可能是从这项研究中学到的教训之一。我们所有人都能更好地打破规则的另一种方法是保持对周围发生的事情的关注。有时我们太专注于手头的工作，以至于我们没有看到这种情况如何为我们提供展示领导力和真实性的机会。莫里斯·奇克斯（Maurice Cheeks）在2003年4月25日的NBA季后赛中就有过这样的机会。莫里斯是波特兰开拓者队的主教练，他的球队在系列赛中以0-2落后。那是
a high stakes moment. And now she won her America and salute the men and women serving our country with our national anthem. Twenty thousand excited basketball fans are in the Rose Garden in Portland. The crowd falls silent as a nervous looking 13-year-old girl walks toward the microphone. Please welcome as voted by you the fans are winner of the Toyota Get the Feeling of a star promotion Natalie Gilbert. At first things go well. Natalie looks confident, relaxed. And as you can hear, she is making a mistake. She's looking for her father to get some support, and then somebody shows up to help her.
一个高风险的时刻。现在她赢得了她的美国，并用我们的国歌向为我们国家服务的人们致敬。两万名兴奋的篮球迷在波特兰的玫瑰园。当一名看起来很紧张的13岁女孩走向麦克风时，人群安静了下来。请欢迎由你们粉丝投票选出的丰田“感受明星”活动的获胜者娜塔莉·吉尔伯特（Natalie Gilbert）。起初事情进展顺利。娜塔莉看起来自信、放松。正如你所听到的，她犯了一个错误。她在寻找她的父亲以获得一些支持，然后有人出现来帮助她。
It's Maurice Cheeks. At a moment when you might think that all his attention would be focused on his team and their chances in the game, Maurice has the presence of mind to realize that a child is in trouble. He has a daughter about Natalie's age. He rushes up to stand beside her. He drapes an arm around her and says, come on, come on. Come on, come on.
是莫里斯·奇克斯。在这样一个时刻，你可能认为他所有的注意力都会集中在他的球队和他们在比赛中的机会上，莫里斯有意识地意识到一个孩子遇到了麻烦。他有一个和娜塔莉差不多大的女儿。他冲过去站在她身边。他搂住她，说：“来吧，来吧。来吧，来吧。”
Star lies, let's... Star lies. Last dream. Last dream. Natalie hesitates. She doesn't know this stranger in the grey suit who has come up to stand by her side. But Maurice Cheeks is now singing,
星光，让……星光。最后的梦想。最后的梦想。娜塔莉犹豫了。她不认识这个穿着灰色西装站在她身边的陌生人。但莫里斯·奇克斯现在正在唱歌，
and Natalie is lifted along. Natalie looks confident again, her voice soars. And then something happens in the stadium, thousands of fans, the players, they see what Maurice has done. And now, everyone is singing. It is triumphant. And I'm afraid And the home of the brave I often use the video clip in class and then the question that I ask after the clip is
娜塔莉被带动起来了。娜塔莉看起来又自信了，她的声音高亢。然后体育场里发生了一些事情，成千上万的球迷、球员，他们看到了莫里斯所做的事情。现在，每个人都在唱歌。这是胜利的。我害怕，勇敢者的家园。我经常在课堂上使用这个视频片段，然后在片段之后我问的问题是
does this guy have a good voice? And he doesn't. And what is interesting is that he took him no time to walk in and help. He made himself vulnerable in front of 20,000 fans and millions of viewers from home. That's what rebels do. They are not worried about what others are thinking, but they make themselves vulnerable, in a way that gained them respect from those around them. There is something infectious about authenticity. There is authenticity, is contagious.
这家伙唱歌好听吗？他唱得不好。有趣的是，他没花时间就走过去帮忙。他在2万名球迷和数百万在家观看的观众面前让自己变得脆弱。这就是叛逆者所做的。他们不担心别人在想什么，但他们让自己变得脆弱，以一种赢得周围人尊重的方式。真实性具有某种感染力。真实性是会传染的。
Once we see people making themselves vulnerable, rather than judging them negatively, we actually respect them and we ask ourselves questions about why is it that we're covering up? We should be more willing to be authentic as well and bring ourselves forwards as we interact with others. There's something I've often thought about when I see people do brave things and I ask myself, you know, are they being fearless or is it actually something else? And as I watch this clip, Francesca, it occurred to me that maybe authentic people are not fearless. It's just that the passion they have for the things they care about is greater than their fears. I think that's what I'm seeing with the basketball coach. I think it's certainly an element of it. You're seeing that the person is
一旦我们看到人们展现出脆弱的一面，我们非但不会负面地评判他们，反而会尊重他们，并开始反思：为什么我们要掩饰自己？我们也应该更愿意展现真实自我，在与他人互动时表现出本真的一面。每当我看到人们做出勇敢的行为时，我常会思考：他们是真的无所畏惧，还是其实另有原因？观看这段视频时，Francesca，我突然意识到，也许真实的人并非无所畏惧，只是他们对所关心的事物的热情超越了恐惧。我想我在那位篮球教练身上看到的正是这一点。我认为这确实是其中的一个因素。你看到那个人正在
struggling and the first thought that comes to mind is, oh my gosh, I don't have a good voice. I can help here. You just see a person who needs help and you walk in without the worry of what others are actually thinking. Again, it's more of where is that you're keeping your focus? And too often we walk through life or we come to work, being very much focused on impressions that we're making on others and what they're gonna see in us, what it is that we're gonna comment on when I put an idea forward and he didn't.
挣扎，脑海中浮现的第一个念头是：天哪，我虽然不擅长表达，但我能帮上忙。你只是看到一个人需要帮助，于是就走过去，而不去担心别人会怎么想。同样，这更多取决于你关注的焦点在哪里。我们太常在生活中或工作中，过于关注自己给他人留下的印象，在意别人会怎么看我们，在意当我提出一个想法而他没有采纳时，别人会怎么评论。
He wasn't worried about that. He was more focused on the fact that there was somebody there who could use the help and he knew, and he was close enough that he could in fact step in and help. One of the pieces of research that I remember you doing some years ago has to do with the phenomenon of humble bragging, where people essentially play down what they are doing as a way to sort of show up, how good they are. And in some ways, there seems to be a difference between vulnerability
他并不担心这些。他更关注的是，那里有人需要帮助，而且他知道，他离得够近，确实可以介入并提供帮助。我记得你几年前做过的一项研究，是关于“谦虚式炫耀”现象的，人们本质上通过贬低自己的行为来变相展示自己有多优秀。在某些方面，脆弱与谦虚式炫耀之间似乎存在差异，
and humble bragging, but I don't quite know how that distinction comes about. With humble bragging, what you're trying to do is say something that is about one of your accomplishments or something that you achieved, but you're trying to be indirect with making yourself vulnerable or talking about your mistakes. You're being very direct and you're trying to be indirect with making yourself vulnerable or talking about your mistakes. You're being very direct and you're being authentic. And people really see through that. There is research that shows that people almost experience in authenticity in others. And there is almost like, I don't want to be close to that person because they're being in authentic.
但我不太清楚这种区别是如何产生的。在谦虚式炫耀中，你试图说出关于你的一项成就或你所取得的成果，但你试图通过一种间接的方式来表达。而在展现脆弱或谈论错误时，你表现得非常直接，并且力求真实。人们真的能看穿这一点。有研究表明，人们几乎能感知到他人的不真诚。而且会产生一种“我不想接近那个人，因为他不真诚”的感觉。
And instead when we are making ourselves vulnerable, when we are willing to speak up about our weaknesses, we're basically telling the world, we are telling others that we are not perfect, that we are humans. One of the things that makes this book so interesting, Francesca, is that you've spent so much of your career exploring the pitfalls of breaking the rules.
相反，当我们展现脆弱，当我们愿意谈论自己的弱点时，我们实际上是在告诉世界，告诉他人我们并不完美，我们是普通人。Francesca，这本书之所以如此有趣，原因之一在于你职业生涯的大部分时间都在探索打破规则的陷阱。
And of course, this is a standard fare for many academics. We've had co-authors of yours like Docker, Calthenaer and Dan Arieli on the show talking about unethical behavior, the risks of power. Powerful people often feel they can break the rules act with impunity. In some ways, it makes sense that many of us are nervous about rule breaking because we've seen the consequences of rule breakers and lots of times breaking the rules doesn't lead to good consequences. Fundamentally breaking rules and being rebellious means leaving what's comfortable and known and familiar. And so people perceive it as risky business, but what the book hopefully teaches us, or at least in looking at the story of these rebels, what I've learned is that it might feel uncomfortable at first, but really it does pay off. We are more confident when we're breaking rules.
当然，这对许多学者来说是常规课题。我们节目曾邀请过你的合著者，如Docker、Calthenaer和Dan Arieli，讨论不道德行为和权力的风险。有权势的人往往觉得他们可以打破规则而逍遥法外。在某种程度上，我们许多人对打破规则感到紧张是有道理的，因为我们见过规则破坏者带来的后果，而且很多时候打破规则并不会带来好的结果。从根本上说，打破规则和叛逆意味着离开舒适、已知和熟悉的环境。因此，人们认为这是冒险的行为，但这本书希望能教会我们，或者至少在观察这些叛逆者的故事时，我学到的是：虽然起初可能会感到不适，但它确实会有回报。我们在打破规则时会更加自信。
We also are much more engaged in the activities that we are working on, and we also end up with better, more trusting relationships. So there is a lot of goodness that comes from rule breaking, but we do need to shift our thinking. It's rule breaking that is constructive, Is rule breaking that is constructive? Not rule breaking that is destructive. So when I think about a lot of the years that I spent looking at cheating
我们也会更加投入到正在进行的工作中，并最终建立起更好、更信任的关系。因此，打破规则会带来很多好处，但我们需要转变思维。是具有建设性的打破规则，是具有建设性的打破规则，而不是破坏性的打破规则。所以，当我想到我花了很多年研究欺骗
and why is it that people steal and what organizations could do about it, that's rule breaking that is destructive. But the type of rule breaking that we're talking about now, though risky or uncomfortable, it's rule breaking the leads to positive change. I'm wondering if the distinction is as simple as that though. Isn't it possible that in some ways people who break the rules can in fact go over the
以及人们为什么会偷窃，以及组织可以对此做些什么时，那是破坏性的打破规则。但我们现在讨论的这种打破规则，尽管有风险或令人不适，却是能带来积极变革的打破规则。不过，我怀疑这种区分是否真的那么简单。难道在某种程度上，打破规则的人确实可能越过
edge? I remember visiting Facebook many years ago, and there were posters on the walls saying, move fast and break things. And Facebook, of course, was an enormous rebel success story in Silicon Valley. But increasingly, a lot of people feel the company has gone too far, that it's broken too many rules,
界限吗？我记得多年前参观Facebook时，墙上贴着“快速行动，打破陈规”的标语。Facebook当然是硅谷一个巨大的叛逆成功故事。但越来越多的人觉得这家公司走得太远了，它打破了太多的规则，
that it's actually run afoul of what we think a company should be doing, even on questions of national security and democracy. And I understand the point you're making, it would be nice if we could easily demarcate the rule-breakers who are constructive from the rule-breakers who are destructive, but isn't it possible that there is actually a pretty thin line between the two? When I think about the various businesses and organizations that I studied as I was working on the book, I've noticed a couple of things that seems to be really important when we think about this thin line.
甚至触犯了我们认为公司应该遵守的底线，即便是在国家安全和民主等问题上。我理解你的观点，如果能轻易区分建设性的规则破坏者和破坏性的规则破坏者固然很好，但这两者之间难道不存在一条相当模糊的界限吗？当我思考在撰写本书时研究过的各种企业和组织时，我注意到在考虑这条模糊界限时，有几点似乎非常重要。
First is the fact that in businesses where people are encouraged to break the rules, the leaders are very clear on the rules that should not be broken. Context in which you absolutely need to follow the guidelines or the rules. So one example that comes to mind is aerial investment. As Chicago based mining management firm, if you were to visit the firm, what you would see is that the leaders are really trying to make sure that people are staying open-minded, that they're using all the talents that I talk about in the book. But if you go to certain places, everybody in the firm is going to tell you there, you got to follow the rules.
首先，在鼓励人们打破规则的企业中，领导者非常清楚哪些规则是不应该被打破的。在某些情况下，你绝对需要遵循准则或规则。我能想到的一个例子是Ariel Investments，这是一家位于芝加哥的资产管理公司。如果你去参观这家公司，你会发现领导者确实在努力确保员工保持开放的心态，确保他们运用我在书中谈到的所有天赋。但如果你去到某些部门，公司里的每个人都会告诉你，在那里，你必须遵守规则。
So for example, if a letter goes out to a client, everybody knows that the three different people need to look at the letter to make sure that it's clear, that there are no typos, that is the language is appropriate because otherwise you would have fact that the repetition of the firm negatively. That's a rule that everybody knows should not be broken. So as these examples suggest, there is much clarity around the rules that really you don't want people to break. And second, and other things that I noticed in businesses that encourage rebelliousness is the fact that once you trust people to break rules, they seem to have very good judgment. They sort of decide on their feet the situations where you really
例如，如果有一封信要发给客户，每个人都知道需要有三个人审阅这封信，以确保内容清晰、没有错别字、语言得体，否则会对公司声誉产生负面影响。这是一条每个人都知道不应打破的规则。正如这些例子所暗示的，对于那些你确实不希望人们打破的规则，有着非常明确的界限。其次，我在鼓励叛逆精神的企业中注意到的另一件事是，一旦你信任人们去打破规则，他们似乎就具备了非常好的判断力。他们会当机立断，判断出在哪些情况下你真的
should be putting your head down and follow the script rather than using your mind in a creative way to come up with a different solution. So that type of good judgment is something that I've seen in so many different rebels and in so many organizations where people are encouraged to be rebellious. You sometimes describe this as positive deviants in the book, but of course in many companies and organizations, someone who comes along and says, let's do things differently, the way we've been doing things all this time has been wrong. I mean, that person is often seen as a troublemaker. Often times what's different between a troublemaker and a rabble in the way I think
应该埋头苦干、遵循剧本，而不是发挥创造力去寻找不同的解决方案。这种良好的判断力是我在许多叛逆者和许多鼓励叛逆的组织中看到的。你在书中有时将其描述为“积极的越轨者”，但当然，在许多公司和组织中，如果有人站出来说“让我们换种方式吧，我们一直以来的做法是错的”，那个人往往会被视为麻烦制造者。我所认为的麻烦制造者和叛逆者之间的区别，往往在于
of rabbles is the delivery. Many people after I was working on the book and they heard about it, asked me to go and watch them in their work because they, I'm clearly a rebel, but it's not paying off for me. And so in a couple of cases, I did go, and I was watching them as they were interacting with their colleagues, and the elements of rebelliousness were there, but the delivery was wrong. So they were coming across as arrogant.
表达方式。在写书期间，许多人听说后要求我去观察他们的工作，因为他们觉得“我显然是个叛逆者，但并没有得到回报”。于是，在几个案例中，我确实去了，观察他们与同事的互动，叛逆的元素确实存在，但表达方式错了。他们表现得过于傲慢。
If they were in a discussion, and they thought that the discussion needed to go in a different direction, rather than saying, I see the value in your idea and I think we can also bring to bear a different perspective. They were more shutting down the idea, letting the person know how wrong the idea was, prior to bringing in forward their ideas. They were the troublemakers, maybe people are breaking rules, just for the sake of breaking rules. Rapples instead are really being constructive
如果他们在讨论中认为讨论需要转向不同的方向，他们不是说“我看到了你想法的价值，我认为我们也可以引入一个不同的视角”，而是直接否定对方的想法，让对方知道这个想法有多错误，然后再提出自己的想法。他们是麻烦制造者，也许人们只是为了打破规则而打破规则。而叛逆者则是以一种真正具有建设性的方式
in their approach in a way that creates positive change. I'm wondering how writing and researching this book has changed your own life. How have you tried to internalize these lessons at home as a parent, as a partner, as a friend, as a colleague, and as a professional. In all spheres of life, I've changed my behavior quite a bit, or at least I find myself pausing and trying to learn how to be an effective rabble.
来处理问题，从而创造积极的改变。我想知道撰写和研究这本书如何改变了你自己的生活。作为父母、伴侣、朋友、同事和专业人士，你是如何尝试在家庭中内化这些经验的？在生活的各个领域，我的行为都有了很大的改变，或者至少我发现自己会停下来，尝试学习如何成为一个有效的叛逆者。
There is a story that I tell in the book about my son, who at the time was about four and a half year old. This is the time where curiosity is as it is. You keep asking why and what type of questions. And it's early in the morning. And Alex is my son name is having his breakfast. So a bowl of milk with some cereal. And as is sitting at the counter, steering his milk,
我在书中讲过一个关于我儿子的故事，当时他大约四岁半。这是好奇心最旺盛的时期。你会不停地问“为什么”和“是什么”之类的问题。那是一个清晨，Alex（我儿子的名字）正在吃早餐。一碗牛奶泡麦片。当他坐在柜台边搅拌牛奶时，
he looks at my husband and says, Daddy, do we still have the coloring bottles that we use to use when we color exit Easter? So my husband is sort of looking confused, but he says, yes, and he walks through the cabinet, he opens it up and gets the bottle to Alex and said, Alex, what are you going to do with it? and gets the bottle to Alex and said, Alex, what are you gonna do with it? And Alex smiled and said, I'm gonna color my breakfast. And you should have seen the face of my husband
他看着我丈夫说：“爸爸，我们还有以前复活节涂色彩蛋时用的那种色素瓶吗？”我丈夫显得很困惑，但他还是说“有”，然后走到柜子前打开它，拿出瓶子递给Alex，问道：“Alex，你要用它做什么？”Alex笑着说：“我要给我的早餐上色。”你应该看看我丈夫的表情，
who was confused, sort of disappointed. And it looked back at Alex and said, Alex, we don't do that. And Alex, being a four and a half year old boy, said, why not? Very reasonable question. And then my husband even more confused with Alex's answer, looked at me and said,
他感到困惑，甚至有些失望。他看着Alex说：“Alex，我们不那样做。”而Alex作为一个四岁半的男孩，问道：“为什么不呢？”这是一个非常合理的问题。然后我丈夫对Alex的回答更加困惑，他看着我说：
we don't do that, right? And that was a beautiful moment for me. As we were trying to struggle through this question or whether we do it or we don't do it, Alex opened up the bottle and started to put red coloring in his milk and all of a sudden the cereals were happily swimming in pink milk. And it's a perfect example of how often we go through life and there are rules that we put out there that maybe should be questions.
“我们不那样做，对吧？”那对我来说是一个美好的时刻。当我们试图纠结于“我们该不该这样做”这个问题时，Alex打开了瓶子，开始往牛奶里滴红色色素，突然间，麦片就在粉红色的牛奶里快乐地游动了。这是一个完美的例子，说明我们生活中经常遵循一些我们设定的规则，而这些规则也许本该是值得质疑的问题。
Why is it that milk needs to be white for breakfast? I actually tried it, so I now had pink milk, yellow milk, green milk, and it tastes just the same to me. If anything, you're really smiling as you start off your day. Francesca, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Really fun to be talking to you, so thank you. Francesco Gino is a professor at Harvard Business School and the author of Rebel Talent, why it pays to break the rules at work and in life. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Kristen Wong, Autumn Barnes, Ryan Katz, and Andrew Chadwick.
为什么早餐的牛奶必须是白色的？我其实试过了，我现在喝过粉色牛奶、黄色牛奶、绿色牛奶，对我来说味道是一样的。如果说有什么不同，那就是你在开始新的一天时真的会微笑。Francesca，非常感谢你今天参加《Hidden Brain》节目。和你聊天真的很愉快，谢谢你。Francesca Gino是哈佛商学院的教授，也是《叛逆的天赋：为什么在工作和生活中打破规则是有益的》一书的作者。《Hidden Brain》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的制作团队包括Bridget McCarthy、Laura Quarelle、Kristen Wong、Autumn Barnes、Ryan Katz和Andrew Chadwick。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Tom Webster. Tom is a senior vice president with Edison Research. For many years, Edison has provided the radio and podcasting industry with insights about where our field is headed. I've long appreciated Edison's analytical approach to some of the big questions facing media companies.
Tara Boyle是我们的执行制片人。我是《Hidden Brain》的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是Tom Webster。Tom是Edison Research的高级副总裁。多年来，Edison一直为广播和播客行业提供关于我们领域发展方向的见解。我一直很欣赏Edison对媒体公司面临的一些重大问题的分析方法。
When I recently reached out to Tom with a specific data question, he quickly followed back up with an answer. Thank you, Tom, for your help. Next week in our Work 2.0 series, the benefits and costs of working from home. You know, for me, I'm really missing my colleagues. I like being at home, you know, I live with my wife and four kids, but it kind of gets isolating,
当我最近就一个具体的数据问题联系Tom时，他很快就回复了答案。谢谢你，Tom，感谢你的帮助。下周在我们的“工作2.0”系列中，我们将探讨居家办公的利弊。你知道，对我来说，我真的很想念我的同事。我喜欢待在家里，你知道，我和妻子还有四个孩子住在一起，但这有点让人感到孤立，
and I'd loved to go back into the office at least for two, three days a week. If you're a fan of Hidden Brain, or maybe looking for a holiday gift for a loved one, be sure to check out our new online shop. We have Hidden Brain t-shirts, mugs, water bottles. You can find it all at shop.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantum. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我很乐意每周至少回办公室工作两三天。如果你是《Hidden Brain》的粉丝，或者正在为亲人寻找节日礼物，请务必查看我们的新在线商店。我们有《Hidden Brain》的T恤、马克杯和水杯。你可以在shop.hiddenbrain.org找到所有这些商品。我是Shankar Vedantum。很快再见。目前本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。